i'm a hypothetical for you right you're  pregnant you're driving in texas you get  pulled over in the hov line says hey  you're supposed to have other people in  hov lane why are you driving with just  one person she goes i'm pregnant in the  states that want to make abortion  illegal you should be able to drive with  a baby in your belly in the ajv new tax  dependence as soon as you're pregnant  that's the tax dependence that's my  child he's alive when does child support  start when the kid is born right why on  the earth would it start when the kid is  born yes life begins a contradiction  if you want to get a discount at a movie  you should be allowed to do that if  you're pregnant yeah if you're pregnant  you should have to pay for you and the  kid that's in that movie if you're going  to see the minions movie double it up